et le chien prochain prochain approche
est reproché aux militaires des lots des
affaires pendant les grands de chez leur
maman et à l'intérieur approchez
approchez passer pour la petite dame
qu'est ce que ce sera un gros pardonner
s'il vous plaît mon avis oui voilà je
vous présente monsieur est un attaché
culturel militaire d'ambassade
c'est un grand pays ami et il aimerait
beaucoup que je vous comprenez ils ont
des problèmes à leurs frontières
maintenir l'ordre alors fait messi a
frappé à la bonne porte
je n'ai pas frappé à la porte et c'est
tout va tout seul quand je suis entrée
libre
c'est une image que vous avez a proposé
à monsieur bien tout dépend tout dépend
est-ce que vous avez besoin de chez pas
pour une petite guéguerre honoré par
action une guérilla urbaine
mais les maquisards ou alors ou alors je
ne dis pas ça un regard attendri des du
caire mondiale
la maison peut toujours dire oui il est
très bien écouter dans l'eau mais c'est
un conflit larvé offrira des gobelets
tibia ça oui oui mais je voudrais
frapper un grand coup
n'est ce pas oui alors je voudrais
savoir si vous avez des exo 7b les
messieurs l'attaché culturel
je m'excuse mais votre pays n'a pas de
marine alors l'exemple c'est vrai mais
là dans le catalogue j'ai vu dans les
exercer mais dites moi oui ça fera bien
dans le bureau du président obama will
on va vous hip hop et les résidents can
marine emballé c'est pesé attendez des
quads aux ça fait un peu beaucoup
peut-être mais non mais non vous savez
nous chez nous c'est comme laisser la
ferme le 13e et gratuit des toits dans
le catalogue
oui il est beau il n'avait pas d'argent
à non nous n'avons pas d'avion mais je
peux vous communiquer le numéro de
monsieur marcel d'accord avec moi aussi
dans le catalogue là haut j'ai vu il est
beau mais vous faites le bon choix
c'est notre dernier modèle vous savez
revue je ne vous raconte pas vous avez
30 cm de blindage c'est avec la charge
creuse avec un viseur à infrarouge on
peut tuer la nuit c'est un plaisir là
nous sommes on les voit pas ses yeux
et le maniement est traçable monsieur le
conseiller c'est le principe du
suppositoire vous êtes road usa
je suis très intéressé mais le problème
c'est que la couronne ne plaît pas aux
égouts t on quand on est malade alors si
vous voulez aller pour peindre aux vert
bleu jaune comme vous voulez on
m'attendait d'accord si vous voulez mais
ce qui me faut dresser les initiales du
président ils affronteront la té le
président ghislain grandisson pas ou pas
du tout alors pourquoi pas des
paillettes sur les exocet depuis la
stéréo la moquette dans les chars
d'assaut un gros marché alors si vous le
ratez vous alors disons qu'à 10 bazooka
de caisse et les 50 pages aucun bien
comme ça voilà monsieur le conseiller
oui si vous voulez mettre pour haïti
mais des oreilles j'te de parcourir du
tout moi ça me prêter une oreille
attentive une image juste une oreille
alors je voulais vous présenter notre
nouveauté c'est une arme très propre
pour une guerre à visage humain c'est
une volée oui elle détruit les gens et
elle est parmi régira super g à chevry
dites moi j'ai vu aussi dans le
catalogue
je voudrais 12 h à l'espace avec la
glace entre nous mais en prime la queue
du tigre qui pourront pas les
décalcomanies et oui les décalcomanies
j'avais les coller sur les jeannois même
vous avez fini c'est tout ce qu'il vous
faut non ça je crois que oui mais vous
absolument plus besoin d'eux attendez il
ya peut-être un problème je voudrais
savoir au niveau de l'entretien du
service après vente a aucun problème là
oui après vente un problème juste un
coup de téléphone et m'a dit mon sort je
connais de ces délits que ça passait du
bon travail
si vous voulez donner une certaine
gauche la victoire militaire d'ambassade
voilà merci beaucoup
dites moi la note est salée mais on sait
comme les cacahuètes mais ce n'est pas
grave ça nous allons aller au ministère
le ministre l'a servi de ça vous savons
travers non mesdames et messieurs a fait
mais si vous vouliez revenir demain nous
avons 30% de lire active de réduction
sur les bons rails
c'est formidable on trouve vraiment de
tout regard des mitraillettes